speaking of relationships though can we
flash back to your time
on the wwe with the bella twins there
was a little tension there let's be
honest you're all moms now what's the
relationship like
it's great it's great we text a lot and
you know nikki just had a baby
yeah a beautiful little boy and uh so we
we text a lot a lot
a lot of random questions you know
random questions
it's a woman thing okay well our rachel
smith
just caught up exclusively with the
sisters and joins us from nashville
they're all about that mom life now huh
rach
yes they sure are it is such a special
time for them both but especially new
mom
nikki hi matteo
i'm obsessed with being a mom it's the
greatest thing in the world
the twin sisters had their babies just
22 hours apart
in hospital rooms next door to each
other one priority
filming the births which will be
featured this season on total bellas
premiering tomorrow on e
we went in with like camera luggage set
up like three different camera angles so
we wouldn't miss anything
well it was funny because i remember
when arden was setting everything up
one of the nurses came in and she just
like looked around like what
this is intense like people are filming
themselves nowadays
we have a selfie like three tripods and
iphone cameras like
just crazy they're so bad you've been
documenting your workouts online
for your fans and everything like that
nikki what have you noticed differently
about your body
i'm not gonna lie like when i see myself
naked i get
sad at times and i try not to and i try
to embrace like
like when i look at matteo go okay this
is worth it but it is weird to see your
body change so much always in the mood
i have a feeling we're going to see more
little uh bellas running around here
uh-oh not from this end she took hers at
her tubes out
why did you really make that decision so
you know this pregnancy was an accident
but i'm so happy i mean now i can't
imagine life without buddy
but i'm like that's it and then my
husband and i can have fun the rest of
our lives and not worry
now nikki when are you adding to uh your
crew i think i'm one and done
i love you